à quelques mètres de la tour de
télévision
au moins cinq à drap pour les recouvrir
ils sont entassés dans une simple
camionnette
on peut chez les habitants moitié vous
de voir
ils veulent
complets
jeanne la tour de télévision frappé hier
par un missile
très vite les pompiers sont intervenus
pour éteindre l'incendié
ils ont ensuite vérifié dans les étages
qu'il n'y avait pas de blessés ni de
personnes à évacuer
pour ce français la nuit a été dur la
sason trois fois ça veut dire une taxe
sur les immeubles quand la sirène d'
alerte retentit
[Musique]
vite
quitter l'appartement et se mettre à
l'abri
dans le centre de kiev l'endroit le plus
sûr c'est le métro
il est à plus de 100 mètres de
profondeur en bas on s'organise le quoi
boire et manger car l' alerte peut être
longue
cette femme explique qu'elle va mal
parce que c'est la guerre sa voisine une
vieille dame née en 1934 lui a dit que
les allemands n'étaient pas comme ça
avec nous
les troupes russes ne sont toujours pas
rentrés dans kiev selon les autorités
américaines la colonne est toujours
immobile à plus de 25 kilomètres de la
capitale ils font face à une résistance
plus importante que prévu ils ont aussi
des problèmes d'approvisionnement dans
de nombreux cas les colonnes sont
littéralement à court d'essence et elle
commence à maintenant à manquer de
nourriture pour leurs propres troupes la
résistance ukrainienne s'organise toutes
les bouteilles disponibles sont utilisés
pour confectionner des cocktails molotov
pas sûr que cela puisse empêcher la
vence de chars russes